donc nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir donc nous
accueillons aujourd'hui pour cette
audition Monsieur Arnaud Gaillot vous
êtes producteur de compé et de Morbier
installé dans le doux en policulture
élevage et après en avoir été le
secrétaire général de 2019 à 2022 vous
êtes depuis cette date président du
syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs Madame
Véronique marchessau vous êtes éleveuse
en allettante dans le morbillant et vous
êtes la secrétaire générale de la
Confédération paysane après en avoir été
pendant plusieurs années l'une de ces
secrétaires nationales je suis toujours
secrétaire national et vous êtes
toujours secrétaire national donc c'est
un attelage qui certes ne va pas de soi
mais une configuration qui a le mérite
de permettre une écoute et un dialogue
avec toutes les sensibilités après
l'audition que nous avons eu la semaine
dernière avec le président de la FNSEA
et à l'instant même avec le président
des chambres d'agriculture je tiens
quand même à préciser
Jean-Claude que nous avions également
proposé à la Coordination Rurale d'être
représenté ce matin mais que cette
organisation a décliné notre invitation
et malheureusement l'agenda de la
Commission ne permettait pas de recevoir
de plus petits syndicats comme par
exemple le MODEF que cependant nous
n'oublions pas mais après ce cycle nous
aurons entendu trois organisations qui
pèsent 3/4 des voix aux élections
consulaires et si la Coordination Rurale
avait accepté notre invitation cela
aurait fait 98 %. monsieur le président
madame la secrétaire générale j'imagine
que vous voudrez revenir en quelques
mots sur la crise agricole que nous
venons de traverser je rappelle à toutes
fins utiles les différences qui vous
caractérisent a priori les jeunes
agriculteurs on on participé directement
aux négociations qui ont conduit aux
deux paquets d'annonces du Premier
ministre axé avant tout sur l'allègement
de la pression normative y compris en
matière environnementale pour lever les
contraintes pesant sur la production les
jeunes agriculteurs ont appelé avec la
FNSEA à mettre fin au mouvement la
Confédération paysane a également été
entendu par le gouvernement mais tendz à
proposer un autre récit de la crise que
nous venons de traverser
davantage explicable selon elle par la
problématique des revenus agricoles trop
faibles et trop inégaux différence de
taille la Confédération appelle toujours
à poursuivre le mouvement de
protestation pour nuancer cette
opposition schématique les jeunes
agriculteurs ont également beaucoup
insisté ces derniers jours sur le
nécessaire respect des lois égalim afin
d'assurer un juste prix de la matière
première agricole et la Confédération
paysane n'est pas en reste pour dénoncer
les tracasseries administratives de la
PAC difficile à assumer en particulier
pour les plus petites exploitations un
autre point commun qui vous réunit est
l'attention que vous portez l'un et
l'autre l'une et l'autre au défi du
renouvellement des générations à l'heure
où un agriculteur sur deux atteindra
l'âge de la retraite d'ici à 2030 et
entre installation et agrandissement il
me semble que vos de organisations
placeent le curseur plutôt du côté de
l'installation donc plutôt qu'une
audition rétrospective sur les raisons
de la colère qui ne vous empêchera pas
bien sûr de la faire nous souhaiterions
vraiment vous entendre sur comment vous
vous projetez vers les prochaines étapes
et notamment les étapes législatives
donc vous entendre sur les 11 articles
de l'avantprjet de d'orientation sur le
renouvellement des générations en
agriculture pouvez-vous nous donner
votre avis en particulier
sur trois mesures structurantes de ce
texte la question foncière et l'outil
des groupements fonciers agricoles
d'investissement le nouveau guichet
unique de l'installation de la
transmission France service agriculture
et le diagnosticque modulaire de
l'exploitation lors de l'installation ou
de la reprise d'une exploitation jugé
trop peu structurant pour les ans ou au
contraire porteur de contraintes
nouvelles pour les autres enfin jusqu'où
de on selon vous ouvrir le champ du
projet de loi à venir enfin le Premier
ministre a parlé de l' de l'ajout pardon
d'un volet simplification et ou
compétitivité et le Sénat avec la
proposition de loi pour un choc de
compétitivité en faveur de la ferme
France de notre collègue Laurent Duplon
rapporté par notre collègue Sophie prima
dispose d'ors et déjà d'un éventail de
propositions dans lesquelles le
gouvernement ne s'est d'ailleurs pas
privé de puiser pour ces annonces
récente il me semble que vous seriez
tous les deux d'avis d'ouvrir davantage
ce texte mais que les dispositions
supplémentaires sont celles sur
lesquelles vos vues seraient
potentiellement les plus divergentes
voilà je vous laisse la parole madame la
secrétaire générale peut-être allez-vous
commencer et ensuite monsieur le
Président ben je vais bonjour à toutes
et à tous je vais commencer par faire un
petit retour sur la crise agricole qu'on
vient de vivre ces dernières semaines
pour nous elle vient de loin elle nous a
pas du tout surpris le malaise agricole
il est profond il est
connuin depuis longtemps le nombre de
fermes diminue le nombre de paysanes
paysans agriculteurs agricultrices est
en chute libre les les suicides sont
sont nombreux dans notre
profession c'est une traduction du
malaise qu'on du malaise qui qui existe
qui est profond dans notre profession et
et là en fait
c'est ça a été une expression de ce
malaise là
qui donc du coup qui s'est exprimé parce
que il y avait des des contraintes
administratives parce que il y avait du
coup une détaxation du un abandon de la
détaxation du GNR parce que il y avait
des problèmes climatiques mais en fait
le problème il est très profond et le
problème il est lié à notre revenu donc
du coup depuis depuis le début nous on
porte la nécessité de s'attaquer à ce
problème à ce problème du coup de
revenus on fait vivre tout un un
écosystème au sens système économique
au-dessus de nous en dessous de nous en
fait que ce soit la Val ou l'amont qui
vit sur notre travail et qui du coup n'a
pas du tout intéresse que le système ce
système évolue puisque il en bénéficie
largement et et c'est nous qui faisons
la variable d'ajustement et c'est
pourquoi il y a des fermes qui
disparaissent c'est pourquoi il y a des
paysans et des paysanes des agriculteurs
des agricultes qui arrêtent leur métier
donc c'est vraiment euh c'est vraiment
une crise profonde qui est vu qui est du
à l'absence de revenus et à l'absence de
perspective en fait toutes les solutions
qui nous ont été apportées par Monsieur
hatal lors de ces divers ces diverses
annonces ont été des mesures de court
terme certes nécessaires pour une partie
d'entre elles he on va pas on va pas le
dire que tout tout est à jeté il y avait
des mesures d'urgence liées aux
problèmes sanitaires des mesures
d'urgence au problèmes climatiques qui
étaiit nécessaire à prendre mais on n
pas de en fait il y a pas de vision à
long terme il y a pas de changement
structurel par ces annonces on s'attaque
pas à la à la question de notre revenus
nous on revendiqué depuis le début de
reprendre la question du prix que il y
est vraiment inscrit dans la loi que nos
produits agricoles ne puissent pas être
achetés en dessous de nos prix de
revient notre prix de revient tenant
compte à la fois de nos coûts de
production mais aussi notre revenu et
dans notre revenu notre protection
sociale et en fait on a toujours pas
cette garantie là les lois égalimes
successives ne l'ont ne le permettent
pas d'une façon garantie d'autant plus
qu'elles sont pas très bien appliquées
mais mais déjà à la base elle ell ne
constitue pas cette assurance et on
demande aussi une protection par rapport
à au commerce international et c'est
pour ça qu'on est qu'on demande l'arrêt
des accords de libre échange tout du
moins de sortir l'agriculture des
accords de libre échange qui mettent qui
mettent notre agriculture en compétition
avec les agricultures du monde entier et
les agricultures aussi de l'Europe et
qui mettent à mal nos du coup nos fermes
et et là aussi touche à notre revenu
donc pour ces raisons-là nous on est
toujours on n pas arrêté la mobilisation
aujourd'hui il y a des Confédérés qui
sont mobilisé à Chalon en Champagne on
va continuer à porter nos mobilisations
tant qu'on a'ura pas des engagements sur
l'assurance de ne plus pouvoir vendre
nos produits en dessous de nos coûpts de
revient et sur la la protection par
rapport au commerce international qui
est extrêmement délétaire pour notre
agriculture par un engagement sur
l'abandon des sur la sortie de
l'agriculture des accords de libre
échange donc voilà très rapidement pour
le contexte aujourd'hui on reviendra sur
la suite après comme vous voulez ou si
vous voulez déjà sur par rapport à ce
que vous attendez du futur projet de loi
ou alors je vous cache pas que par
rapport à la loi d'orientation agricole
on a été extrêmement déçu on s'était
impliqué mais je pense comme tous les
syndicats agricoles euh dans la
proposition de du contenu de de la loi
qui devait être une loi très ambitieuse
et déjà nous dès le départ on prenait
cette nécessité de s'attaquer à la
question du revenu qui était pour nous
unéalable en fait on peut pas avoir
d'installation agricole on peut pas
avoir de maintien des fermes si cette
question du revenu n'est pas prise en
compte donc dès le début on a avait on
avait demandé à ce que la question du
revenu soit prise en compte dans le dans
cette loi d'orientation agricole donc ce
qui n'a pas été fait et et donc voilà
aujourd'hui c'est crucial que qu'on doit
revenir là-dessus que cette ce projet de
loi doit y revenir et ben je pense qu'on
reviendra peut-être dans les questions
sur les proposition qu'on avait porté
euh d'accord je vais laisser la parole à
mon collèg ok madame la secrétaire
générale monsieur le Président
oui bonjour madame la Présidente chers
sénateur membres de la commission
affaires
économiques rapidement revenir quand
même sur les mobilisations qu' ont eu et
vous avez fait
contre-rendu d'une partie de ce qui
s'est passé mais quand même saluer la
mobilisation de l'ensemble du du réseau
J et rappeler quand même
que contrairement à d'autres nous sommes
en action depuis le mois d'octobre et
que nous avons pas eu et nous avons pas
attendu la tentation de des stabiliser
un pays ou de se met des troubles
irrévocables et que ça fait un moment
qu'on qu'on alerte notamment avec les
panneaux à l'envers sur le fait de d'un
malaise agricole et qu'il est temps de
d'entendre et et et de comprendre les
revendications qu'on le fait quand même
plus plus de 500 action plus de 40000
agriculteurs mobilisés euh donc voilà
être fier quand même du réseau jeune
agriculteur pour la tenueun grande
partie des actions dans le respect des
biens et des personnes même si il y a
sûrement des débord à des endroits à
noter mais comme je l'ai souvent rappelé
le modor chez nous est assez clair le
respect des biens et des personnes que
les lois de la République sont pas mis
en suspens parce que nous sommes en
mobilisation et que chacun devra assumer
ses actes si il y a
lieu vous dire que la remobbligation
elle elle passe avant tout sur le
changement de logiciel le changement de
logiciel il veut dire dire beaucoup de
choses mais c'est qu'il y a un moment
donné il faut qu'on arrive à retrouver
dans ce pays que quand nous représentant
parlons avec vous élu les actes derrière
se produisent sur le terrain et sur le
territoire parce qu'on sent une quand
une déconnexion à plusieurs titres
d'exemples mais voilà il y a quand même
un problème là-dessus ce sentiment quand
même de finalement toujours plus mais
finalement sans contrôler ce qui rentre
chez nous sur
l'alimentation ce sentiment de vouloir
toujours faire mieux même au sein de
l'Europe avec des normes qui sont pas
forcément respectées ailleurs en Europe
et au-delà de ça je pense un un autre
vrai problème c'est le le sentiment de
mal-être agricole qui pêche chez
beaucoup de gens nemp pêche qu'il
s'exprimait c'est ce sentiment fait
finalement d'être toujours la la le
responsable le responsable du mal-être
des animaux le responsable de cet
environnement qui est en train de se
détruire finalement le responsable de
tous les mots qu'il y auraient sur cette
planète à l'heure actuelle et le
sentiment d'être la cible idéale alors
peut-être parce que nous sommes plus que
400000 à l'heure actuelle et que
finalement nous sommes moins importants
que d'autres mais quand même un
sentiment assez généralist là-dessus et
bien sûr un sujet en lien avec le revenu
et bah l'application pleine entière des
galimes euh certes il y a aussi du
boulot chez nous sur la
contractualisation mais on l'a vu encore
quand même là sur les négociations
commercial c'est quand même tendu c'est
compliqué et donc à un moment donné à à
faire appliquer moi je le dis assez
facilement euh je pense que tout le
monde se lève le matin pour gagner de
l'argent ce qui est problématique c'est
quand des gens commencent à gagner
beaucoup d'argent sur le dos des autres
parce qu'ils leur rendent pas la juste
valeur de ce qu'ils leur doivent et donc
ça il faut qu'on arrive à à le changer
et et à le faire prendre en compte et et
comment on le fait je pense qu'on a un
besoin quand même dans ce pays mais j'y
reviendrai de savoir à un moment donné
comment on repositionne notre
agriculture qu'elle soit française mais
qu'elle soit même européenne dans ce
monde global où beaucoup de choses
bougent beaucoup de positionnement fait
et finalement quelle agriculture on
choisi de faire dans notre pays et
comment on le fait et ça j'y reviendrai
peut-être à travers le pacte et la loi
euh et vous l'avez souligné qu'on a
participé aux négociations avec le
gouvernement notamment sur les sujet du
mois de la simplification parce que ça
c'est quand même quelque chose qui qui
pose pas mal de de problèmes ces
contraintes cette
suradministration où par exemple on vous
on vous demande de conserver pendant 5
ans les beau d'enlèvement comme quoi la
coopérative est venue chercher les
animaux chez vous et que finalement vu
que c'est écrit au crayon quelques
années plus tard c'est effacé on y'y
voit plus rien euh et j'en passe et des
meilleurs et donc sur ça il y a il y a
un gros boulot à faire et là-dessus en
lien avec les préfet je pense qu'il faut
qu'on avance sur ça sur bien sûr les
mesures d'urgence euh on pas les reciter
mais que ça soit la MHE les versement
pâack parce qu'à un moment donné quand
on nous on doit l'argent à l'état on
nous on n pas trop de délai par contre à
l'inversement que il y ait encore des
gens qui soient pas payés de la grippe
aviaère de la tuberculose c'est pas
c'est pas normal euh bien sûr des
mesures en faveur de l'origine France
parce qu'on avait quand même obtenu il y
a à l'époque l'étiquetage d'origine
obligatoire qui avait été cassé au
niveau de la Cour européenne mais on
sent quand même une dérive qui est
repartie avec le Madine France euh parce
que oui dès l'instant qu'il est passé
dans une vine français indirectement il
y a une patte française mais derrière on
se rend compte que l'origine bah est pas
est le plus souvent pas d'origine
française c'est indirectement une une
tronterie pour nos consommateurs les
mesures sur la la compétitivité
notamment sur le TDE des chaauur les
travails saisonniers je pense là nos
amis viticulteur à filière filière Arbo
fruits et légumes qui est quand même en
souffrance et là je pense que c'est un
point pas négligeable pour eux et bien
sûr toutes les les mesures de
surtransposition les cofyo alors on a
beaucoup été attaqué là-dessus j
peut-être un peu moins que le syndicat
de la FNSEA mais pourquoi avoir demandé
l'arrêt d'cophyo c'est qu' m donné quand
il y a eu un écophyo 1 qui a pas marché
un écophyo 2 qui a pas marché marché et
qu'on fait un écofy 3 avec exactement
les mêmes
ingrédients si tout le monde fait un peu
de cuisine si on reprend la même recette
et que finalement tout le monde a trouvé
la soupe mauvaise faut pas recommencer
sinon on finira exactement pareil et
donc la la stratégie là-dessus elle est
dire à un moment donné comment on trouve
un un logiciel qui nous permet sur les
phytosanitaires de se trouver une
stratégie assez claire et nette de se
dire ok il y a une trajectoire à avir
qui finalement personne ne pourrait
contester de dire comment on préserve un
environnement qui est toujours mis à à
de plus en plus en tion par le fait
d'une population qui augmente par le
fait de nouvelles technologies par ceci
par cela mais qu'on garantit des niveaux
de production et un environnement donc
retrouver de l'intelligence retrouver
finalement quand même la mise en avant
des efforts faits par Agriculture parce
que hicofito comme il est fait
actuellement ne récompense jamais les
efforts agricoles et quoi qu'on fera on
sera toujours mauvais donc là-dessus on
a le sentiment d'avoir comme éé entendu
ceci il va falloir vraiment lancer le
travail et qu'on aboutisse d'ici ça et
enfin quand même nous euh qui n'est pas
négligeable pour Jia des engagements euh
pour aller plus loin sur l'installation
et la transmission notamment le
réhaussement du budget de laitaa euh qui
est l'accompagnement installation
transmission euh avec une enveloppe qui
est portée à 20 millions au lieu de 13
millions euh des mesures fiscales et
sociales qui ont été annoncées qui
pouvent se faire d'mitier mais surtout
un calendrier pour travailler d'ici le
prochain PLF euh pour aller encore plus
loin sur sur la transmission et aussi
euh comment on pourrait lutter contre
l'inflation des taux qui je vous le
cache pas actuellement avec des taux
comme on le connaît tous qui pénalise
pas mal les reprises d'exploitation
agricole en ce
moment maintenant le travail j'ai envie
de dire est face à nous et c'est pour ça
que nous avons appelé à suspendre la
forme de mobilisation on na pas arrêté
on a suspendu cette forme de
mobilisation de blocage et qu'on a
appelé notre réseau à les retravailler
comme on le fait tous les jours en tant
que responsabl syndicaux nous au
national mais aussi en région en
département avec bah les services de
l'État euh toutes les personnes qui
auront envie de travailler pour bah
faire avancer ce qu'on a pu obtenir sur
les mesures de simplification sur les
changements de logiciel sur les ga sur
l'installation sur la transmission bien
sûr le calendrier de fin février avec le
rendez-vous du salon de l'agriculture où
il faudra quand même que les premiers
actes d'engagement d'un de comment de
prise de conscience et de volonté de
changer doivent se faire sentir et d'ici
juin ou plus tard à voir quand même ce
CCI le package qui montre que ça y est
on est parti sur une nouvelle forme et
une une nouvelle base avec bien sûr des
élections européennes qui arrivent au
mois de juin aussi et qui pourront aussi
un marqueur et et un rendez-vous qu'on
qu'on se tâchera de de faire sur la ploi
comme vous avez
demandé j'aimerais quand même insister
sur le fait qu'on sera quand même
vigilant à à ce qu'on garde quand même
l'aboutissement de cette loi et c'est ce
qu'on a rappelé pendant les négociation
qu'on puisse profiter de la loi pour
mettre des mesures de simplification des
des mesures sur des normes tout ça nous
ça nous paraît judicieux parce que c'est
un outil législatif on sait très bien
qu'il y a des mesures qui étaient
demandées par les agriculteurs qui
passent par le le cadre législative vous
avez parlé de la PPL
compétitivité oui après il faut pas que
cette loi soit reportée j'ai envie de
dire auot à Noël il faut quand même
qu'on reste sur le le timing je pense
que beaucoup de choses sont déjà prêtes
en plus existent donc il faut juste que
rapidement les personnes concernées se
mettent autour d'une table et de voir
comment on atterrisse assez rapidement
sur cette loil parce que que même si
tout n'était pas au rendez-vous dans la
loi et oui elle avait changé de nom
d'ailleurs elle s'appelait plus loi
d'orientation et d'avenir agricole
ça'appelit loi pour le renouvellement
des générations agricoles parce que elle
comporte quand même un gros volet que ça
soit sur la promotion métier dans les
écoles l'attractivité du métier comment
communiquer auprès d'un grand nombre
vous l'avez vu il y a il y a une
proposition qui est qui serait
l'ambition que toutes les écoles aillent
dans des fermes et ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'important qu'on connecte
la nouvelle génération avec
l'agriculture et quand les jeunes sont
all dans les ferm on sait qu'ils en
parlent le soir et avec les parents ça
crée ça crée du dialogue il y a quand
même des mesures sur l'installation sur
sur la
formation vous l'avez parlé sur le
guichet unique nous c'est quelque chose
qu'on avait fait nîre d'un rapport
d'orientation en 2020 en disant qu'il a
un moment donné c'est pas possible de
continuer d'avoir des gens finalement
qui savent pas où aller quand ils ont
envie de s'installer qui ont du mal à à
trouver les réponses et donc le fait
d'avoir un guichet unique c'est que
c'est clairement identifié où c'est que
c'est et où ça se porte après sur le
débat de qui les porte moi je je
l'entends moi je pense qu'à un moment
donné les Chambres d'agriculture sont un
outil institutionnel sous tutelle quand
même de
l'État représenté par le suffrage
universel qui est le principe
démocratique de notre pays donc un
moment donné je je veux bien que on dis
que c'est pas le bon qu'il porte mais
qui de plus neutre à l'heure actuelle
dans l'agriculture pour porter cet
outill euh à moins que on veuille
changer de système dans ce pays mais à
l'heure actuelle j'ai pas l'impression
qu'on qu'on veuille remettre en cause
notre système démocratique vous dire
quand même que quelques points nous nous
nous nous inquièteent sur sur la loi et
notamment mais ça on l'a poussé au
premier Premier ministre et et j'ai
plutôt le sentiment qu'il l'a entendu et
que ça sera enlevé mais c'était le
diagnostic sol euh parce que la première
chose est assez simple c'est que vu que
l'Europe en débat actuellement il nous
semble pas opportun que la France fasse
un cadre avant même de savoir ce que
l'Europe fera et donc on ça nous paraît
pas bon d'une et la deuxième chose c'est
que on n' pas été capable vraiment de
nous expliquer qu'est-ce qu'on voulait
faire avec ça donc ben j'ai envie de
vous dire que vu qu'il y a quand même un
sentiment de méfiance entre le monde
agricole et une partie de la classe
politique au moins de ces institutions
on préfère rester rester prudent nous ce
qu'on avait poussé c'est plutôt un
diagnostic généraliste qui permet euh de
faire une étude de
l'exploitation pour voir la durabilité
de l'exploitation qu'elle soit sur la
partie économique en terme de de
rentabilité en terme de potentiel de de
filière qu'elle soit sur le l'adaptation
au changement climatique comment la
ferme est positionner pour se préminir
demain au changement climatique en
fonction du climat en fonction des aléas
en fonction de ses cultures qu'on puisse
conseiller le jeune au moment de son
installation on est bien sur du Conseil
parce qu'il y a un moment donné ça reste
aussi de la liberté d'entreprendre et on
va pas obliger à à à faire les
prescriptions mais au moins il
conseiller et qu'il a tous les éléments
sa position au au moment où où il
s'installe et ça fait le lien avec la
volonté de renforcer quand même le côté
formation alors il y a la formation
scolaire il à un moment donné on pourra
pas tout demander à l'école parce que on
va pas faire sortir les gens à 40 ans de
l'école mais il faut aussi qu'on ait la
possibilité de la formation continue euh
toutes les enfin vous avez beaucoup
d'autres corps de métier où les gens se
forment tout au long de leur carrière
que ça soit pour de la monté en compét
sur des postes mais aussi pour que ça
soit de l'acquisition de compéten
personnelle et de la progression
là-dessus faut pas se le cacher je je
pense qu'on est trop faible encore sur
le monde agricole et ça il faut qu'on
l'encourage encore plus et et qu'on le
pousse encore plus parce que qui peut
prétendre tout savoir
euh jusqu'à finalement la la fin de sa
vie si je peux utiliser cette expression
là on en apprend tous les jours et donc
faut qu'on puisse en permanence amener
nos nos nos agriculteurs nos
agricultrices à se remettre en cause à
se poser des questions et à à s'enrichir
de de ce qui se passe
autour vous dire que sur le sujet
foncier on vous cache pas que chez
jeunes agriculteur on l'a plutôt vu avec
réticence alors oui on entend parler
renouvellement desjation par
l'installation sans parler
foncier oui mais comment et et pourquoi
ouvrir une boîte de Pandore sur le
foncier sans avoir déjà identifié les
vrais leviers avoir pu mettre tous les
acteurs autour d'une une table et
discuter parce que chacun il voit son
intérêt personnel mais peut vite trouver
aussi que il a peut-être plus à perdre
qu'à gagner si on ouvre vraiment tout et
qu'on y va à fond moi j'attire votre
attention sur notre système agricole
français qui est en grande partie et
dont c'est le cas pour ma part sur le
système du fermage et de la mise en
baille et on n pas beaucoup
d'agriculteurs qui sont propriétaires de
leur terrain notamment en élevage
notamment dans des fermes de de taille
moyenne ou dans des dans des zones où
d'ailleurs on a des fortes valeurs
ajoutées beaucoup sont en location
beaucoup sont en fermage et le fermage
permet quand même l'accès à des jeunes
qui ne sont pas issu de famille agricoes
qui sont pas issu de famille aisé
d'accéder au métier et de pouvoir
reprendre une exploitation sans avoir un
pactol à l'investissement tout ça ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas s'interdire
de travailler à comment rendre le
fermage attractif et volontaire ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut s'interdire de
travailler comment on peut mettre des
outils de fermage en placefin ou des
outils de portage du moins des outils de
portage parce qu'il y a un moment donné
il faut pas qu'on puisse laisser partir
notre notre sol si je puis dire à
l'extérieur de ce pays mais comment on
le fait intelligemment et donc à voir
comment comment on peut comment on peut
l'anticiper comment on peut le faire et
et ce qui nous manque encore et qui est
absent est ce que je saisait le lien
avec ce qu'on disait sur les mesures
transmission on avait fait un livre
blanc sur la transmission avec beaucoup
de propositions qui restent certes à
l'heure actuelle généraliste il faut
rentrer ceci dans le mécanique dans le
détail mais pour ça il faut aussi que
Bercy se mette à travailler aussi avec
nous euh pour euh proposer quelque chose
parce que moi je veux bien entendre dire
que nos idées sont pas les bonnes mais à
un moment donné faut me proposer quelque
chose en retour et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
en place on peut pas s'indigner que des
Chinois viennent acheter des vignobles
mais que finalement le vigob peut pas
être pris par les enfants d'une de
génération qui ont construit ce vigum là
pendant des années donc on peut faire
les grands discours mais ça serait bien
qu'il y ait les actes et donc on a
besoin de de mesures de transmission
forte et je pense que c'est de
l'investissement certes c'est une
dépense nette à l'instant T mais c'est
un investissement pour l'avenir parce
que ben c'est garder un patrimoine
national c'est garder des outils de
production sur notre sol et c'est permet
à à avoir comme vous le dites une
souveraineté alimentaire dans ce pays et
je pense que le mot souveraineté pour
les plus aguéris est en train de prendre
tout son sens dans les crises qu'on
traverse l'Ukraine le conflit ukrainien
nous rappelle à quel point finalement la
fragilité peut être vite rapide et et je
pense que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
ont oublié que au moment du où tout
était fermé ou tout est arrêté les
rayons ne sont jamais vidés donc c'est
bien quand même la preuve qu'on a une
puissance agricole en France et que ça
serait bien qu'on la qu'on la conserve
euh donc pour en finir et pas être plus
long dans dans les propos d'introduction
vous dire qu'on qu'on compa comme on a
toujours qu'on qu'on demandera votre
soutien et et le travail qu'on a qu'on
mène toujours avec vous sur cette loi
sur ces packs sur ce qui va arriver
aussi sur les mesures de simplification
vous dire que vous nous trouverez à vos
côtés pour pour travailler euh comme
nous l'avons toujours fait euh parce que
c'est la physiologophie de notre
syndicat et moi en tant que Président
c'est que nous sommes un syndicat à
politique et que nous travaillons avec
tout le monde euh et puis quand je vois
qu'on qu'on nous targue d'être proche du
pouvoir vous me permettrez la petite
boutade de dire que finalement du coup
je sais pas si nous sommes de droite de
gauche ou du centre avec vu que nous
avons 60 60 ans d'existance et que nous
avons toujours été targués proche du
pouvoir finalement je sais pas de quel
bord nous sommes donc c'est c'est la
réponse que que je ferai à nos amis et
voilà euh enfin c'est ce que je pouvais
vous dire mais je pense qu'on porte
l'ambition vous dire en conclusion que
les jeunes croi en ce métier les jeunes
croient en la souveraineté alimentaire
croient en leur métier on le voit dans
nos lycées les lycées sont plutôt
remplis avec des gens qui ont envie je
pense qu'il faut juste qu'on redonne
confiance à cette jeunesse agricole
comme ils se font le rêve Amérique he
leur rêve australien que finalement dans
ces paysl avec quelques idées
quelquestion en poche c'est possible et
ben comment on retrouve cette même envie
là dans notre pays parce que on a les
chercheurs on a les entreprises on a la
qualité on a l'excellence il faut juste
qu'on redonne confiance à cette jeunesse
et qu'on arrête de laisser croire que il
y a pas d'avenir que tout est fi et que
la seule solution c'est la récession
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la secrétaire générale avant de passer
aux questions vous voulez revenir sur
quelques points peut-être bah du coup
moi je vais je vais vous dire un petit
peu ce qu'on avait porté pour cette loi
d'orientation puisque je m'étais arrêté
plutôt à l'analyse de la de la situation
actuelle donc sur l'orientation et la
formation nous on avait vraiment porté
de continuer à soutenir largement
l'enseignement agricole il a beaucoup de
de propositions qui ont été faites qui
permettent plutôt de faire de créer des
des nouvelles formations qui ne sont
peut-être pas nécessaires il faut
peut-être donner plus de moyens à celles
qui existent déjà garder le rôle
d'expérimentateur
dans pour les pépinières d'entreprise
parce qu'effectivement aujourd'hui on a
affaire à un nouveau public qui n'est
pas en lien de façon familial ou proche
avec le milieu agricole donc vraiment
leur donner la possibilité de pouvoir
être se tester avant de vraiment faire
ce métierl
euh sur
le sur l'installation et la transmission
donc c'est vraiment l'installation pour
nous vous savez qu'on prône d'avoir au
moins un million de paysanes et de
paysans pour pouvoir répondre aux jeux
d'alimentation et et en même temps
répondre aux enjeux
environnementaux et climatiques qui sont
qui sont très prignignants aujourd'hui
donc pour ça al pour avoir des
installations nombreuses nous tout comme
les J on pense que le foncier c'est un
c'est une pierre angulaire de ces
installations et tout comme du coup mon
collègue qui vient de parler la
préservation du droit du fermage c'est
quelque chose à qu'on va qu'on défend
bec et ongles c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui il y a encore des
fermes qui qui
restent familial à taille humaine et du
coup il faut vraiment vraiment protéger
cet outil euh protéger aussi garder les
saaires et renforcer leur leur action et
un peu faire évoluer la gouvernance ça
nous paraît nécessaire puisque ça a
permis de maintenir l'agriculture à sans
une évolution vers une agriculture trop
trop industrielle même si elle en prend
le ch
donc préserver les terres agricoles les
répartir le foncier donc par ces outils
de régulation que sont la safaire et par
le fermage travailler à la
restructuration et à la division des
exploitations surcapitalisées
aujourd'hui qui ne sont plus
transmissible encadrer les montages
sociétaires et interdire le travail à
façon intégrale qui du
coup fait sortir complètement
l'agriculture ENF participe à la
financiarisation de l'agriculture
l'accès à l'eau aussi le partage de la
ressource en eau est un point à
travailler énormément donc on
l'introduction d'un droit au revenu ça
je vous en ai déjà parlé tout à l'heure
renforcer notre protection sociale aussi
avec les AD logements le droit au
remplacement donc qui a été amélioré
dans le dernier projet de loi de
finances mais on peut encore aller plus
loin parce qu'en fait il pourrait aussi
bénéficier à d'autres productions que au
sol éleveurs peut-être doit-on y mettre
une un plafond pour les revenus mais en
tout cas il y a plein d'autres fermes
que les fermes d'élevage qui aujourd'hui
ont besoin de faire des de s'arrêter un
peu de de pouvoir prendre des des congés
soit
pour soit pour se reposer comme tout un
chacun soit pour se former et donc du
coup il faut améliorer encore ce ces ces
congés de remplacement
euh accompagner euh donc à toutes les
étapes de l'installation et la dans et
surtout la diversité des profils donc
aujourd'hui dans le dans le projet de
loi qui nous est proposé il y a un
guichet unique qui serait du coup porté
par les Chambres d'agriculture euh
pourquoi pas si on a la garantie quand
même que tous les tous les les parcours
peuvent être accompagnés et surtout avec
une révision de la gouvernance des
chambres puisque aujourd'hui la
gouvernance des chambres ne laisse aucun
une place au syndicat minoritaire dont
la Confédération paysane fait partie on
pèse très peu sur les politiques qui
sont accompagnées par les Chambres
d'agriculture et donc nous on demande du
coup une révision de la gouvernance des
chambres on demande à ce que le la
reconnaissance de du coup du de de tout
des gens qui ont voté pour nous et et
c'est pas fait aujourd'hui dans la
répartition des siège ni dans la
répartition des financements voilà donc
on demande ok pour le guichet unique
mais avec une révision de la gouvernance
des
chambres mais euh on voit aussi ce que
ça donne en agriculture aujourd'hui la
crise elle ne vient pas de nulle part
elle a été c'est des politiques
publiques qui nous ont mené là et elles
ont été accompagnées par juste une
fraction de de du
syndicalisme le syndicalisme majoritaire
effectivement mais quand même mais qui
nous a qui nous amené là où on est
aujourd'hui après euh vous nous avez
parlé du choc de de la loi du choc de
compétitivité qu'on retrouvait beaucoup
dans les annonces aujourd'hui de
Monsieur
hatal Nous on peut pas dire qu'on est
vraiment réjoui par ces annonces
l'agroécologie a été abandonné dans le
projet de loi mais aussi a été sacrifié
dans les annonces de Monsieur
hatal l'objet de la colère en fait pour
nous a été détourné la colère des gens
qui se sont exprimés c'était pas une
colère contre les normes c'était c'était
une colère contre le fait de ne pas
pouvoir pouir vivre de son métier et
donc on
pour oh oh oh il y a pas d'expression
quelle qu'elle soit monsieur sadem pour
euh en fait pour calmer cette colère on
l'a détourné on l'a détourné vers le
vers l'environnement vers le soutien à
l'agroécologie qui a été complètement
sacrifié et on trouve que c'est assez
dramatique pour l'avenir de de
l'agriculture on est les premiers en
fait les premiers les premières victimes
quand il y a des quand on utilise des
pesticides quand on diminue la
biodiversité on va être quand on quand
on a plus quand on garde plus l'eau dans
les sols c'est c'est notre production
qui est la première victime c'est nous
qui en sommes les premières victimes et
donc du coup on ne peut pas opposer
agriculture et environnement il faut
vraiment qu'on arrive à concilier les
deux c'est euh c'est une question de
pérénité de l'agriculture c'est une
question de survie de
l'humanité et euh pour le je vais
revenir à des à d'autres points
du de de la loi donc sur le diagnostic
modulaire aujourd'hui il existe beaucoup
de diagnostics dans dans beaucoup de
réseaux qui sont qui permettent à aux
agriculteurs agricultrice quel que soit
le stade de de leur vie professionnelle
de faire des points et donc on pense
qu'il faut vraiment tenir compte de
l'existence de ces diagnostics pour
accompagner l'installation et la trans
mission n'est peut-être pas obligé de
tout réinventer il y a des choses qui
sont très efficaces aujourd'hui
euh et voilà et je vais revenir un petit
peu sur du coup sur sur le plan écofyo
qui a été abandonné euh il a été
abandonné parce que effectivement il
était ça ça a été une demande du
syndicalisme majoritaire dans cette
crise euh il avait pas fait ses preuves
sur les sur les diverses moutures
précédentes après
c'était à au chambes d'agriculture de
les mettre en œuvre elles l'ont
peut-être pas fait de la façon de façon
à ce que ce soit super efficace parce
que moi je peux vous dire que dans les
fermes il existe des pratiques des
pratiques avérées dans de nombreuses
fermes et depuis longtemps qui
permettent de diminuer les pesticides
voire de s'en passer et on devrait
vraiment déployer massivement ces ces
pratiques pour faire évoluer
l'agriculture on n'a pas à s'opposer les
uns les autres il y a pas d'un côté la
bio d'un côté l'agriculture
conventionnelle on doit tous se mettre
ensemble c'est pas nouveau on doit tous
se mettre ensemble et euh
et utiliser les pratiques qui peuvent
être favorables à tout le monde et les
pratiques qu'on utilise en bio elles
peuvent être très bien favorables à ceux
qui ne qui n'y sont pas donc il y a une
nécessité d'accompagner le déploiement
de ces pratiques d'accompagner la
recherche aussi euh
pour du coup pour évoluer euh dans un
sens qui soit favorable aux attentes
citoyennes et aux urgences du moment
et enfin dans les dans les projets dans
les groupes de travail de recherche qui
sont proposé dans le cadre de cette loi
nous on propose qu'il y ait un groupe de
travail qui qui qui explore la voie
d'une sécurité sociale de l'alimentation
pour travailler vraiment sur la
souveraineté alimentaire pour travailler
sur le maintien d'une agriculture
paysane et de paysans et paysannes
nombreuses et une alimentation correcte
et choisie pour tous nos concityens et
concit donc on aimerait bien qu'il y ait
un groupe de travail qui explore cette
voie là merci beaucoup madame la
secrétaire générale merci encore
monsieur le Président donc nous allons
passer aux questions on va prendre les
questions de Daniel Laurent de
Jean-Claude tissau et de Philippe
grovallet Daniel oui madame la
Présidente j'ai des questions à poser
mais vous vous avez presque répondu à
mes
questions je crois qu'on a un rôle
important tous ensemble et ici au Sénat
nous l'avons équé depuis longtemps c'est
maintenir notre agriculture compétitive
mais c'est aussi préparer l'avenir et
l'installation des jeunes on ne pourra
pas avoir une une agriculture qui
progresse si on a pas des jeunes qui
sont intéressés qui sont encouragés et
qui sont aidés vous avez parler bien sûr
des des principaux freins à la
transmission agricole l'un et l'autre
mais je crois que un des freins
principaux c'est l'accès au fonciers
agricoes premier point et le financement
bien sûr qui impacte la capacité des
jeunes agriculteurs à s'installer donc
moi j'aurais bien aimé que vous
précisiez un peu vos vos désirs sur ces
deux points parce que c'est l'avenir et
puis surtout ben vous venez de l'évoquer
madame l'agriculture biologique parce
que vous en parliez pas et on sait que
c'est une agriculture qui représente un
pourcentage intéressant d'installation
enfin d'installer et et qui qui a de
grandes difficultés actuellement
et puis je pense qu'il est important et
vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le Président
d'offrir aux jeunes l'impact du
changement climatique parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est en pleine
transition il est important de de
montrer aux jeunes cette cette
transition voilà merci merci Daniel
Jean-Claude tissau merci madame la
Présidente d'abord merci pour cette
l'organisation de cette rencontre il y a
je sais pas si j'ai pas le souvenir
d'avoir eu cette configuration de
syndicat minoritaire donc merci en tout
cas de l'organisation madame la
secrétaire générale monsieur le
président
merci pour vos propos certes un peu long
liiminaire mais je salue la diversité de
votre vision je souhaiterais revenir sur
un sujet qui a finalement été pas
tellement abordé lors de cette crise
agricole qu'on vient de vivre ou qui est
en train de l'on est en train de vivre
c'est celui de la concurrence entre les
productions agricoles et productions
énergique énergétique je pense bien sûr
entre autres à l'agrivoltaïsme dont un
projet de décret est en cours de
consultation et on évoque des taux de
couverture pouvant aller jusqu'à 40 %
des terres agricoles alors je sais que
les J ont déjà exprimé leur crainte
vis-vis de l'agrivoltaïisme et que la
Confédération paysane a souvent rappelé
son opposition pour ce qui est des
terres agricoles alors quelle lecture
faites-vous de ce décret est-ce que
cette surenchère énergétique alors que
les installations sur les toits seraiit
suffisantes ne ne participe pas une
transmiss à une transformation pardon
alors nuisible du métier de Paysan mais
qui pourrait aussi moi je l'avais
soulevé à différentes reprises perturber
le statut du fermage voire le faire
disparaître voilà quel est votre avis et
puis enfin j'aimerais connaître vos
positions sur les évolutions éventuelle
des a PAC on sait que en cas
d'élargissement de l'Union européenne à
l'Ukraine normalement notamment une
réforme de la PAC sera évidemment
indispensable et selon vous quelles sont
les réformes à apporter sur
l'attribution des a PAC que pensez-vous
de la mise en place d'un plafond à
partir d'un certain nombre d'hectares
avec le risque je suis pas naïf avec le
risque de manipulation sociétaire il
vont ferait les grosses grosses
structures fera plusieurs sociétés les
unes à côté des autres pour être sous le
plafond mais voilà qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez et puis ou alors une surprime sur
les premiers hectares merci Philippe
grovallet merci Philippe Grallet s de
l'IRE Atlantique un des rares
départements où la Confédération paysane
a de pendant de nombreuses années
présidé la Chambre d'Agriculture
jeble des collègues ma question porte
sur le le bio non pas évidemment pour
opposer le bio conventionnel ça n'est
jamais constructif mais pour dire que
dans ce département 20 % des
exploitations sont en bio des
exploitations pas de la production mais
20 % quand même c'est dire si ce modèle
ce label en tout cas a permis un
développement vertueux de l'agriculture
dans un département 2è département en
France en surface d'eauù 99 % des masses
d'eau sont en mauvais état donc
vertueuse pour l'environnement pour la
santé pour les agriculteurs eux-mêmes et
surtout et c'est là ma ma question pour
le
revenu on a vu après la crise du lait de
nombreuses conversions en bio qui ont
été financé par les pouvoirs publics
soutenu par les collectivités locales en
tout cas quand je présidais ce
département et et et qui aujourd'hui
sont mis à mal on voit même des des
déconversions ma question porte sur
quelle solution quelle proposition
formuler pour relancer cette filière bio
quand à l'instant le président des
chambres d'agriculture s'en remettait
essentiellement au
marché merci merci madame monsieur pour
répondre à ces trois premières
interventions vous commencez peut-être
madame euh je peux commencer
euh alors sur sur les transmissions
alors je reprends un peu mes papiers sur
les transmissions du coup euh
euh on pense que il faut entre autres
créer une fiscalité incitative à la
transmission parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui si les fermes ont aussi du
mal à se transmettre c'est du fait de la
faiblesse des retraites hein
euh la transmission n'est pas favorisée
par le fait que les retraites sont très
faibles donc du coup les les propri les
les agriculteurs quand ils sont quand
ils sont retraités ils ont plutôt
tendance à pas brader c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire leur ferme parce que
derrière ils ont pas de ils ont pas de
moyens donc il faut aussi s'attaquer au
problèmes des retraites si on veut
s'attaquer si on veut du coup pouvoir
avoir une
transmission et donc les inciter à à
transmettre par un soutien la à la
transmission la revalorisation des
retraites agricoles et le le
plafonnement des zpac à l'âge légal de
la retraite parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de personnes en fait qui
gardent leur terr parce que elles ont
plus de d' pack que elles ont de
retraite et donc ça ne facilite
absolument pas du tout la transmission
euh donc sur la réforme de la PAC donc
nous ce qu'on propose et c'est connu
depuis longtemps c'est qu'on arrête de
de financer la pack à l'hectare mais que
ce soit un financement à l'actif de
façon à ce que ça favorise le nombre de
fermes et que ça que ça ne concentre pas
les subventions dans les plus grandes
fermes donc voilà on va continuer à
appter ça encore et toujours une pâack à
l'actif et donc pas particulièrement
avec le plafonnement du nombre
d'hectctares ou les premiers hectares
puisque on a vu du coup avec le soutien
au premiers hectares les nombreux
montages sociétaires qui permettent de
toucher une fois deux fois 10 fois même
jusqu'à 12 fois on a identifié les 52
premiers hectares donc pour le moment il
y a des contournements qui sont
possibles donc nous vraiment on demande
l'aide à l'actif
euh sur l'énergie euh sur l'énergie bon
pareil hein sur le photovoltaïque vous
connaissez notre position on pense qu'il
y a suffisamment d'endroits où poser des
panneaux photovoltaïques sans s'attaquer
directement aux terres agricooles qui
pour nous doivent rester le support de
l'alimentation euh et si effectivement
on on doit voir la productivité diminuée
du fait des conditions climatiques et
tout ça on n surtout pas intérêt à aller
sacrifier des terres agricoles à la à la
production d'énergie donc les panneaux
photovoltaïque c'est sur les toits et
c'est pas sur les sols euh et sur la
méthanisation bah la méthanisation on a
vu les dérive de de l'industrialisation
de la méthanisation et du fait que
maintenant euh les animaux ne sortent
plus euh en fait ça va complètement à
l'encontre des enjeux de bien-être
animal et des enjeux d'environnement si
les prairies disparaissent c'est parce
qu'en fait les animaux ne paturent plus
et si les les animaux ne paturent plus
parce qu'ils restent en stabulation
toute la journée donc c'est euh c'est
aussi contre-productif pour nos enjeux
environnementaux euh et sur
l'agriculture
biologique effectivement l'agriculture
biologique est aujourd'hui en crise
parce que les nombreuses de
conversion n'ont pas
été parallèles à l'augmentation du
marché après euh ça peut être aussi des
volontés une volonté publique forte si
on estime que cette forme d'agriculture
répond à l'ensemble de des enjeux
contemporains de l'accompagner quand il
y a une crise du port pour quelques
milliers d'agriculteurs on peut
débloquer 270000 € quand il y a une
crise de l'agriculture biologique pour
quelques dizaines de milliers de
producteurs on va on va débloquer 50
millions d'euros donc donc il y a deux
poids de mesure dans l'accompagnement
des des systèmes et en fait il y a peu
de production aujourd'hui qui ne sont
pas accompagné par les politiques
publiques pourquoi on fait pas le choix
d'accompagner l'agriculture biologique
ça c'est la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui on peut faire passer en fait
il y a aucune il y a pratiquement aucune
production agricole aujourd'hui qui qui
en fait s'en sortent uniquement par le
marché c'est une illusion totale de dire
ça il y a aucune il y a vraiment aucune
production donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on
acccompagne pas l'agriculture biologique
pourquoi est-ce qu'on accompagne
d'autres types d'agriculture c'est une
vraie
question donc voilà moi je pense que en
fait faire passer le un cap difficile à
l'agriculture biologique c'est
aujourd'hui une question de volonté
politique monsieur le Président oui
merci sur la question des retraites oui
il faut il faut il faut un complémentet
c'est vrai que souvent on voit que c'est
c'est une question après je pense que le
sujet de la retraite agricole est quand
même aussi compliqué par le système
aussi qui a été faite et je vois
grand-père qui n'est plus de ce monde
mais qui bénéficiait de la retraite sans
l'avoir quotié vous créez quand même un
décalage donc à un moment donné comment
on équilibre aussi un système de
retraite il y a la question des 25
meilleures années à l'heure actuelle qui
est sur la table notamment pour les
conjointes collaboratrice il faut qu'on
trouve une solution parce qu'alheure
actuelle il est pas il est pas résolu et
et là-dessus on compte aussi que ça
puisse évoluer là d aussi à ses
mobilisation qu'on trouve une porte de
sortie pour pour ce sujet-là euh sur le
foncier et les financements sur les
questions de portage moi faut je pense
qu'il faut qu'on voit aussi notamment
euh comment on peut avoir des outils qui
qui qui accompagne la le jeune dans la
reprise ou le moins jeune parce qu'on
aura pas que des jeunes qui
s'installeront au vu de l'ambition ne
serait-ce que déjà de remplacer les 50 %
qui vont partir à la retraite c'est déjà
200000 donc ça fait déjà pas mal de
monde
euh comment on a un outil un fond de
portage mais qui les accompagne sans
faire de la spéculation foncière sans
faire des contraintes à la liberté aussi
d'entreprendre des jeunes parce que moi
je pense qu'il faut aussi être prudent
qu'on est pas des outils fonciers qui
conditionnent un type d'agriculture ou
un autre je pense qu'il faut rester
aussi prudent sur sur ces chosesl mais
il faut il faut qu'on soit rendez-vous
peut-être avec des fonds mais des fonds
nationaux parce que moi je pense qu'il
faut quand même une garantie de l'État
il faut pas qu'on laisse ça des capitaux
il faut je pense du capitaux extérieur
il en faudra parce que peut pas tout
demander à à l'état mais il faut quand
même que l'État soit présent pour
garantir la sécurité qu'il se fasse pas
n'importe quoi et qu'on laisse ça à des
capitaux étrangers qui demain
posséderait le foncier français sur
l'impact du changement
climatique il faut qu'on soit c'était
l'ambition qu'on aurait souhaité qu'il y
ait dans le dans le plus dans le pacte
et pas dans la loi parce que ça c'est
pas la loi mais de comment avec ce qu'on
a actuellement les connaissances qu'on a
je vois le satellite mais comment on est
en capacité avec ce qu'on ce qu'on
connaît avec les prévisions potentiel du
changement climatique nous ce qu'on
aurait voulu c'est comment on modélise
la ferme France demain en fait avec la
l'impact climatique avec les tendances
sociétales avec les besoins de marché et
que potentiellement
je dis dans le l'idéal on serait en
capacité de dire à des jeunes et ben si
vous voulez faire tê typ d'agriculture
alleer plutôt dans cette région là que
rester où vous êtes ou ben
potentiellement demain on fera peut-être
des agrumes dans le sud ça commence fa
ça commence à se faire ça ça arrive et
et pourquoi nous on dit ça chez jeunes
agriculteurs c'est parce qu'en fait on
sait que pour remplacer les 200000
agriculteurs certains le voient comme un
inconvénient nous on le voit comme une
chance c'est qu'on sait qu'on va avoir
beaucoup de jeunes hommes et femmes qui
vont venir qui seront pas issus du
milieu agricole et donc c'est pas des
gens qui vont arriver et c'est pas
péjoratif de le dire mais avec des idées
préconçues d'avoir toujours connu ce
système là parce qu'on sait que pour des
gens qui ont toujours vu ce système là
par leurs parents par par ce qu'on vous
a appris c'est quand même ancré et quand
il faut changer les choses c'est quand
même compliqué pour eux d'admettre que
potentiellement il faudrait abandonner
l'élevage si c'est le cas je dis pas ou
abandonner tel type de cultureal ou tel
type de marchage ou qu'ils l'ont
toujours vu qu'ils ont mis des années
tout ça c'est c'est très compliqué pour
par contre une nouvelle génération qui a
pas forcément ces mêmes attaches ces
mêmes sensibilités ces même patrimoine
c'est qu'on peut arriver à faire ça et
je pense qu'il faut qu'on saisisse la
balle au bon et cette chance là et donc
il faut qu'on puisse aller vraiment et
qu'on rentre plus durement dans la
modisation dans les stratégies de
filière dans Comment on positionne la
ferme France avec tout ce qu'on connaît
et et les besoins la question de
l'eau le la question de l'eau et et du
stockage elle est primordiale après
qu'on chacun point de vue on va pas
faire le débat là parce qu'il serait
éruptif mais moi faud sans il y a pas de
vie et je pense que ça on est d'accord
tous pour le dire après c'est sur les
méthodes sur les façons moi je pense
qu'il y a pas un modèle unique qui
s'adaptera au territoire français
suivant les zones où on se trouve
suivant les les endroits où on se trouve
c'est peut-être plus du barrage c'est
peut-être de la réserve c'est du du
puisement je je sais pas lequel est le
bon mais par contre ce qui ce qui ce
qu'il faut qu'on pousse collectivement
c'est comment on a des concertations
territoriales sur une gestion de l'eau
sur du stockage parce que quand vous
regardez l'épisode qu'il y avait à
l'autom
sur la région Provale d'Azur et
notamment sur les hautalpes ce qui est
passé en volume d'eau dans la Durance
ils ont fait des simulations si pendant
4 jours on avait stocké l'eau qui est
passé dans la Durance on avait un an
d'irrigation pour la région provençale
Côte d'Azur mais au-delà de l'irrigation
c'est surtout le robinet parce que dans
ma région on va pas stocker de l'eau
pour irriguer des prairies ça aurait pas
de sens même si on pourrait le rêver
mais sur un seul calcaire ça a pas de
sens et c'est du bon sens par contre on
vair un sujet c'est comment on abreuve
les vaches et avant d' abreuver les
vaches c'est comment on abreuve les
êtres humains qui ont peut-être oublié
que ça reste des êtres vivants et qui
ont besoin d'eau et que si euh la
première Cuse si vous veut stocker de
l'eau c'est peut-être qu'ils aent de
l'au robiné demain et qu'il puisse qu'il
puisse le faire mais on a un vrai enjeu
à travers le Lot et et et et je prendrai
rapidement l'exemple mais chez moi c'est
des rivières dynamiques on se plaint
qu'elles sont polluées mais en fait
c'est parce que vu qu'il y a manque
d'eau l'été il y a une concentration des
teneurs vu qu'elles ont plus de volume
vu que c'est des poissons qui est des
rivières dynamiques vu qu'il y a plus de
courant elle Meur mais en même temps
vous avez des agences de l'eau par une
directive européen qui finance le
démontage des barrages pour finalement
redonner le libre cours à nos cours
d'eau je pense que là-dessus on marche
vraiment sur la tête parce que si les
anciens l'ont fait c'est qu'il y avait
une raison c'est qu'il y a un sens et
donc il faut il faut qu'on retrouve ça
sur la concurrence agriculture
photovoltaïque euh c'est un sujet euh
qui fait beaucoup débat chez Jia et vous
avez vu nombreuses vois on acheté le le
pavé dans la mar le le point
d'atterrissage qu'on a trouvé nous
semble être un compromis l'idéal ça
serait présenté de vous le dire mais
c'est un compromis entre les territoires
et entre les envies des uns et des
autres euh oui il faut remplir le
maximum qu'on peut sur les toits mais à
un moment donné il faut aussi que on on
fasse pour que ça soit faisable parce
que quand vous voyez les délais de
raccordement qu'il faut pour raccorder
votre installation photovoltaïque sur un
toit c'est pas normal et donc à un
moment donné il faut stimuler les les
ceux qui s'occupent des réseaux pour
être en capacité de de raccorder sur la
question du du
photovoltaïque et donc de
l'agrivoltaïsme parce que il est pas
question qu'on fasse du panneau en plein
champ comme ça peut se faire ça c'est
une aberration mais sur l'agrivoltaïque
je pense qu'il faut pas se fermer les
yeux à à des potentiels quand même
d'accompagnement au changement
climatique je pense à des maréchés vous
avez des installations qui sont en train
d'être testées avec du pilotage
d'irrigation sous le photovoltaïque avec
des sondes piloté avec de l'aspersion
pour du marchage tout ça c'est c'est des
espace test qui existe je pense que
c'est intéressant ce qui est le plus
dommage c'est que chez jeunes
agriculteurs on alertait sur la
situation en 2019 en disant si on fait
rien pour encadrer ça ça va nous péter à
la figure bon ben malheureusement encore
une fois ça va péter à la figure mais en
fait c'est comment on retrouve dans
comment on va toujours mettre de
l'argent dans la recherche je pense
qu'on a trop délaissé la recherche des
fois dans ce pays et et comment on va
chercher plutôt sur ces mesureslà et et
je pense que sur l'ambition qu'on a sur
le renouvellement et sur les énergies
renouvelables on peut pas être contre le
le faux photovoltaïque après il faut
qu'on soit en capacité de le faire
intelligemment l'encadrer et qu'il se
fasse pas tout et n'importe quoi il y a
des choses qui pourraient se faire chez
moi qui se feront pas en î Villain ou
dans le Sud-Ouest parce qu'on a pas les
mêmes paysages on n pas la
même société et donc il faut qu'on ait
cette capacité là mais il y a un moment
donné on peut pas dire il faut sortir
des carburants fossiles et en même temps
dire il faut pas d'éolienne il faut pas
de
photovoltaïque c'est un moment donné
voiture électrique vous me direz comment
elle
roule il y en a quand même qui le font
il y a le nucléaire mais moment donné le
nucléaire avec le retard qu'on a pris il
va falloir quand même trouver des des
sou donc voilà non mais je je pense que
c'est quand même des opportunités
d'ailleurs ça a été soulevé he comment
on concilie nouvell formme moi je suis
convaincu que l'agriculture à sa part à
prendre dans ses nouvelles formes
d'énergie mais par contre il faut les
encadrer oui sur les méthaniseurs il
s'est fait des choses aberrantes mais en
même temps il faut pas je pense
stigmatiser la méthanisation on ferait
une erreur stratégique moi je prends
souvent l'exemple c'est pas parce que il
y a des gens qui font des excès sur de
vitesse sur les routes que tous les
conducteurs sont des forceonnés et vont
donc donc attention à la généralisation
attention à considérer que tout serait
mal mais ça a été dit il faut de
l'encadrement sur ça on a une vraie
carte à jouer et je rappelle quand même
on l'oublie des fois mais l'agriculture
a toujours produit de l'énergie à
l'époque il faisait de la W pour les
chevaux qui tractaient les charus donc
voilà bon aujourd'hui on a des tracteurs
mais voilà il y a la question des
biocarburant nous chez jeun agriculteur
ça fait longtemps qu'on dit comment on
investit pour cette
transition la question du GNR elle est
éuptif mais fondamentalement c'est c'est
c'est un faux sujet alors oui ça
représente une masse parce en fait les
exploitations sont tendu financièrement
mais la vraie question c'est comment on
accompagne la transition comment on fait
pour développer ça et moi je pense qu'on
a des vraies chances et là et la vraie
question qu'il faut qu'on porte et à
travers le PACT au-delà de la
modilisation changement climatique c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans ce pays demain
quelle est la part agricole de
production alimentaire et de production
d'énergie est-ce que c'est 100 %
alimentaire mais ça voudra dire qu'il va
y avoir des choix à faire et
potentiellement revenir en arrière sur
certaines règles parce que ça voudrait
dire qu'il faudra être concurrentiel sur
du marché à l'export et au vu des règles
qu'on a je vois pas comment on peut être
face à des Brésiliens des Ukrainiens ou
des Russes donc je pense qu'il y a des
choses à faire mais il faut se poser
autour des tables et comment on a une
stratégie filière sur l'IDE PAC moi je
pense que la première question qu'il
faudra se poser sur l'Ukraine et on va
pas faire le débat là mais oui il faut
commencer le dialogue mais déjà d'une on
sait tous que ça va pas être demain
parce que comment on fera rentrer un
pays en guerre qui est dans l'Europe je
je vois pas par contre il y aura quand
même des règles parce que l'agriculture
ukrainienne est loin d'être
l'agriculture française et encore même
européenne quand vous voyez comme c'est
fait sans ne serait-ce que prendre
l'exemple des poulets mais quand vous
voyez combien il y a de poulet dans un
bâtiment ukrainien on est loin des
règles françaises sur la PAC les aides
oui il faut toujours y faire évoluer
d'ailleurs jeune agriculteur on l'a
obtenu àortter le fait que si on
demandait les droits à la retraite et
ben on pouvait plus prétendre aux zpac
la limite de l'âge donc il faut
continuer là-dedans mais en fait c'est à
un moment donné comment on se pose
calmement pour avoir une pâack qui
finement accompagne la politique qui est
choisie moi je pense que l'erreur qui a
été fait qui à l'heure actuelle non est
aussi un symptôme de de de la crise qui
se passe là et qui nous plante c'est le
fait d'avoir une pâack dans les années
2000 qui a commencé à prendre un virage
qui était plus forcément un
accompagnement à la production et et un
vrai stabilisateur de prix mais un
accompagnement aux mesures si je puis
dire verte aux mesures environnementales
à l'accompagnement des agriculteurs à
aller vers vers des mesures
environnementales le seul dommage qu'on
a oublié dans la stratégie là c'est que
pour que ça marche fallait que les prix
soient au rendez-vous des produits payés
aux agriculteurs et donc là en fait on a
une déconnexion enfin on a on a la
balance qui qui le fait plus et du coup
on a on a ça donc oui il faut poser les
sujets de la PAC sur la table c'est un
bel outil ça maintient quand même faut
pas qu'on l'oublie un accès à
l'alimentation au mod au plus modeste
des ménages parce que je pense que si on
avait pas la pâack des prix de
l'alimentation exposerait on aurait des
vrais problèmes d'accès à l'alimentation
et pour finir sur la question du bio euh
moi moi je suis convaincu et je l'ai
toujours dit donc je vais pas faire en
torse à à ce que je pense c'est que ce
qui est dommage c'est que le bio a été
construit à coup de politique générale à
cou de campagne politique par des
régions et que finalement il y a eu
aucune concordance de marché en face et
on a fait installer des gens à à à coup
de subvention publique à coup de
maintien sans se soucier de savoir si
euh ce marchélà était porteur ce qui est
dommageable c'est qu'à l'heure actuelle
on a des gens qui sont dans le bio qui
qui l'ont pas choisi comme ces annéeslà
passées pour s'en sortir mais qui est
sont vraiment installés en bio par
conviction et et c'est tant mieux mais
par contre c'est comment on leur apporte
une réponse concrète à ces gens-là pour
les garder dans la filière qui qui est
la l'URE qu'ils aiment et qu'il portent
et donc pour ça il faut qu'on ait une
vraie analyse du marché il faut qu'on
encourage aussi une partie la r
collective à y participer moi je dis
juste attention à à à à à la tentation
de certains de se dire que il y aurait
qu'à aller tout en bio et que le
problème français serait résolu non mais
je dis pas que je je donne mon avis je
dis pas que vous l'avez dit monsieur je
vous dis juste que certains des fois le
le se cèdent et se tente moi je pense
que la France a une richesse c'est sa
diversité et pardonnez-moi de vous le
dire mais moi mon avis personnel c'est
que si demain on était uniforme dans ce
pays avec pardonnezm mot mais je pense
qu'on s'embêterait beaucoup pour rester
poli et je pense que notre diversité et
notre richesse que pour moi il faut des
niches parce que quand vous avez une
niche comme le bio quand vous avez comme
chez moi une niche sur le compté c'est
des c'est quelque chose qui fait qui
tire les autres vers le haut parce que
ça crée de la concurrence et ceux qui
sont en en en conventionnel se disent si
on veut garder des producteurs en
conventionnel il faut aussi qu'on les
paye donc c'est c'est ça et c'est pas
parce que je j'utilise le mot niche sur
20 % que je suis péjoratif moi j'appelle
le compter c'est une niche la plus
grosse AOP de France qui fait 60000
tonnes c'est pas péjoratif de dire que
c'est une niche c'est dire que c'est
quelque chose qui ne représente pas la
ité et pour moi c'est la niche a une
notion d'ancrage au territoire à une
notion de répondre à un marché à une
notion de répondre à des attentes d'un
territoire et c'est là là-dessus et je
pense qu'il y a un moment donné il va
falloir que et je veux vous le dire très
clairement il faut qu'on sorte des
postures quels que soient les uns et les
autres et et l'envie politique il y a
des réalités de terrain il y a des
réalités il y a des gens qui ont pas les
moyens d'aller au bio et vous pourouvez
faire ce que vous voulez ils n'iront
jamais ou alors il faut qu'on se pose la
question du logement il faut qu'on se
pose la question des transports il faut
qu'on se pose la question de nos modes
de vie de tout ça donc il a un moment
donné il faut y aller et moi je vais
vous dire très clairement j'appète de
tous mes vœux qu'on rentre le plus vite
possible dans la planification
écologique parce que là on va mettre
devant on va mettre tout le monde devant
le fait de ses responsabilités de dire à
un moment donné il y a pas de souci
vousouz changer de modèle on y va mais
vous allez voir que c'est pas si simple
et qu'il faut remettre finalement en en
cause le mode de vie général merci
monsieur le Président poser juste une
question non je vais passer aux
questions et puis vous répondrez
peut-être globalement parce que j'ai un
de mes collègues qui s'en va et qui
voulait poser une question on va prendre
les dernières questions patri ch
Jean-Marc boy Daniel Sal et Daniel gr et
si vous voulez faire assez vite merci
madame la Présidente merci madame la
secrétaire générale et monsieur le
Président de de votre présence je
voudrais dire d'abord au représentant
des jeunes qui a un enjeu très très fort
pour la jeunesse en agriculture et bravo
pour votre message il y a quelques mois
on marche sur la tête nos concitoyens
long entendu il ont été sensi parce
qu'il allait sans doute au-delà de la
problématique agricole je reviens très
vite sur la grive voltaïme parce que je
me souviens qu'au moment de du
développement des énergies renouvelables
vous étiez euh l'un et l'autre très
opposés au développement de cela euh et
l'échange a peut-être été un peu court
vous vous aviez raison pour partie
puisque les premiers exemples sont des
contreexemples le mouton àbi enfin j'en
passe ceci étant on découvre maintenant
peut-être avec un peu plus de subtilité
et vous venez de l'évoquer que pour
certaines certaines productions je
prendrai l'exemple de l'arboriculture ou
de la production de fleurs où on est
très déficitaire on a un problème de
souveraineté et à côté on a un problème
de souveraineté en production
énergétique et on s'aperçoit que les
deux peuvent être gagnant gagnant lié au
réchauffement climatique et qu'on gagne
en compétitivité y compris par les
aborculteurs donc je pense que
l'agrivoltaïsme pour moi dans ce cas-là
peut-être peut-être une chance un
complément de revenu un complément de
souveraineté et que peut-être il suffit
de donner à
l'agriculture le portage de cela et que
ce soit lié à un projet agricole mais
mais mais je suis plutôt rassuré de vous
entendre que maintenant il y a une
ouverture à regarder que il y a dans
quelques cas dans certaines productions
il y a un effet bénéfique économique
social toujours quand il y a
l'économique et environnemental merci
Patric Jean-Marc Boyet
oui merci madame la Présidente on parle
beaucoup du renouvellement des
générations de l'installation des jeunes
et je suis étonné qu'on ne parle pas du
tout de l'enseignement agricole parce
que c'est l'enseignement qui conduit ces
jeunes à l'installation à un moment
donné il y a une trentaine d'années 80 %
des jeunes qui étaient en enseignement
agricole étaient des fils d'agriculteurs
et et se destinai à à l'agriculture
aujourd'hui on est seulement à 20 % de
ces jeunes et donc ça pose un problème
d'orientation et et de de d'information
des des jeunes en particulier au niveau
des collèges
mais j'ai pu le constater le le
verdissement des des filières dans
l'enseignement agricole ces 20 dernières
années à travers les bac pro et les BTS
environnement en particulier où on a
biberonné deux générations au bio
sauvetage de la planète sauvegarde de
l'environnement et de la biodiversité
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a énormément de
jeunes qui on en a conduit énormément à
l'échec à l'installation ou s'ils sont
installés on finit à à l'échec à
l'installation alors moi ma question est
de savoir quelle proposition vous pouvez
faire pour retrouver cette attractivité
et pour le l'installation des jeunes en
agriculture toutes les agricultures
merci Jean-Marc Daniel
salmon merci madame la Présidente bon
lorsqu'on rencontre tout le monde tout
le monde dit les agriculteurs doivent
vivre de leurs produits et ça c'est
c'est bien normal simplement comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour ne pas avoir une
concurrence déloyale entre des
agriculteurs qui par leur pratique ont
des externalités positives et des
des externalités négatives avec des
coûts qui sont pris en charge par la
collectivité je parle de potabilisation
de l'eau je parle des questions de santé
avec des épidémies de cancer qui vont
qui sont devant nous et qui sont bien
présentes même déjà là donc on dit ben
on laisse entendre que l'agriculture bio
serait portée à bout de bras par les
aides publiques et ben je pense qu'il va
falloir un jour ce et jeaimerais bien
entendre les jeunes agriculteurs sur ce
sujet là comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
avoir un modèle qui préserve notre
environnement demain à l'heure où
presque toutes les eau de surface sont
pollués même les eaux minérales merci
merci Daniel gremiller
oui merciadame madame la Présidente une
question aux deux
organisations comment fait-on pour
améliorer l'indicateur égalim
puisqueaujourd'hui la preuve les travaux
du Sénat démre que on est en décalage
complet deè question surtout au
président Arnaud président des
j si j'ai bien compris les j sont
effectivement favorable au guichet
unique ça veut dire que la politique
d'installation t historique mené par les
Jia évoluerit d'une manière importante
pour pas dire autre chose ma deuxème
dernière question concernant le
financement de l'agriculture le Sénat a
voté quasiment à
l'unanimité la remise en place des prêts
bonifiés c'est qu'il y a une vraie
question de financement pour
l'accessibilité à l'installation des j
qu'en pensez-vous
et pensez-vous pas qu'il serait
judicieux aujourd'hui de redonner des
perspectives à une installation
progressive en agriculture qui
permettrait bien plus de jeunes de
rentrer dans le métier et à des cédents
de pouvoir effectivement partir
tranquillement quand qui tranquillement
un tuilage bien plus important tel qu'on
l'avait créé il y a déjà très longtemps
merci dernière question Frédéric Buval
rapidement et après on laissera la
parole à nos rap merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Gaillot
je souhaite vous interroger sur les
jeunes agriculteurs des outromèes
l'agriculture l'agriculture ultramarine
est un secteur important en terme
d'emploi qui mérite une attention
particulière notamment pour faciliter
l'installation de jeunes en mobilisant
les moyens nécessaires et en adaptant
les politiques publiques au spécificité
de ces territoirees nous pouvons relever
les défis et garantir un avenir durable
à l'agriculture ultramarine alors pour
répondre au défis auquel ils font face
les agriculteurs ultramarins ont besoin
d'un accompagnement spécifique c'est cet
accompagnement peut prendre plusieurs
formes un soutien financier des aides
financières peuvent être mises en place
pour aider les agriculteurs à investir à
se moderniser et à faire face aux
alliats climatiques un appu technique
des services de conseil et
d'accompagnement technique peuvent être
proposés aux agriculteurs pour les aider
à améliorer leur pratique et à s'adapter
aux nouvelles réglementations et puis il
a promotion des produits ultrarins et il
est important de promouvoir les produits
ultramarins sur les marchés locaux et
hexagonaux alors en conclusion quels
sont selon vous les leviers qui sont à
disposition des jeunes agriculteurs en
notre MRE sur ces trois formes
d'accompagnement je vous remercie merci
voilà donc les questions je vous laisse
la parole monsieur le président madame
la secrétaire générale pour terminer
cette audition madame la secrétaire euh
oui donc sur sur
l'énergie nous ce qui nous inquiète
aussi au aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait on
n on nous pousse à avoir des revenus
issus de l'énergie pour compenser la
faiblesse de nos revenus agricoles et du
coup c'est vraiment ne pas s'attaquer
aujourd'hui à à du coup au problèmes de
revenus qu'on pointe notamment au sein
de C cette crise donc la concurrence
avec l'énergie ça nous pose un problème
à ce niveau-là et ça nous pose aussi un
autre problème par rapport à la
financiarisation de l'agriculture
c'est-à-dire à la présence d'acteurs non
issus du milieu agricole qui rentre dans
ce ce processus de de d'installation lié
à à la production d'énergie donc ça fait
augmenter le coût des du foncier et on
trouve que globalement c'est quand même
assez problématique alors qu'il y ait
quelques cas euh sur lesquels on peut
trouver qu'il y a des avantages ça peut
être assez marginal d'une façon général
c'est plutôt un danger pour la
production agricole de continuer à à
aller vers une un développement
euh fort de la production d'énergie et
dans les fermes sur les installations
alternatives qui seraient beaucoup plus
voué à l'échec que les installation en
en conventionnel bah moi faudrait
m'apporter des chiffres c'est absolument
pas du tout prouvé que les les personnes
qui s'installent sur sur des fermes qui
ne soient pas de l'agricult culture
conventionnelle soit aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus en échec que celle qui
s'installe sur des sur des fermes
classiques
euh
sur les externalités positives et
négatives des différents modes
d'agriculture je ne peux
que acquer c'est
effectivement on ne veut pas soutenir
particulièrement l'agriculture
biologique mais par contre
on on soutient d'une autre façon
l'agriculture conventionnelle en en
prenant en charge sur le plan sociétal
ces externalités négatives donc là il y
a peut-être quelque chose à revoir et
euh ben je voulais vous justement vous
poser une question Arnaud Gaillot tout à
l'heure vous aviez dit que la bio elle
doit s'en sortir avec le marché euh
pourquoi pas le port industriel quand il
est en crise pourquoi pas le vin quand
il est en crise dans ce cas-là il faut
laisser toutes les productions se
débrouiller toute seule avec le marché
euh et après sur euh sur l'amélioration
de des galimes on peut que euh euh
exiger cette amélioration puisque pour
le moment quand on négocie euh les prix
euh à l'intérieur du processus des
galimes la négociation elle est en
défaveur euh du maillon de la production
puisque les le le la trans les
transformateur et
euh les et la vente la grande la grande
distribution euh en fait nous oblige à
adopter leurs indicateurs enfin en tout
cas à pondérer les nôtres parce que
soi-disant il serait pas bon donc il
nous oblig
en fait il nous force
à à ne pas porter nos indicateurs à nous
qui prennent en compte notre production
et pour le moment c'est parce qu'il y a
un rapport de force qui est en notre
défaveur que la loi égalim ne permet pas
ne permet pas qu'on
soit toujours rémunéré de nos coû de
produc de nos prod production
agricole monsieur le Président oui sur
l'agrivoltaisme il y a une vraie
question sur partition de la valeur
c'est pour ça qu'on qu'on le disait que
c'est dans le décret c'est comment on
peut le faire il y a des choses qui sont
réfléchies moi vous dire c'est telle
solution je sais pas mais ce qu'il y a
de sûr il faut voir comment on encadere
la répartition de la valeur et nous ce
qu'on avait pointé dans un rapport qui
remonte déjà il y a quelques années sur
les questions d'énergie on avait déjà un
peu évoqué ça c'est comment en fait on
commet pas les erreurs qu'on a peut-être
fait sur l'alimentaire sur l'énergie et
comment on va au plus loin pour garder
la main éviter que la le maximum de
valeur n nous échappe c'est un point à
travailler je prétends pas avoir la
solution mais il y a un vrai sujet de de
comment on réparti la valeur parce que
l'agrivoltaïsme on on pourra pas la
mettre partout sur le territoire et du
coup comment on arrive à créer quand
même que ça profite à l'ensemble
agricole et et indirectement une
potentiellement des compensations ou des
choses sur la question de l'enseignement
agricole
euh on l'a proposé oui il faut le voir
notamment il y a la question de
l'évolution d'un bachelore de renforcer
ça il faut qu'on renforce les volets
gestion les volets économie euh moi je
pense que c'est bien aussi qu'on est
parce que c'est aussi ça fait partie de
l'attente sociétale que soit enseigné la
question de la de l'agroécologie de ce
changement climatique de tout ça oui il
faut il faut le faire évoluer mais en
fait euh ce qui est dangereux ça ser RCI
dem on a un enseignement qui enseigne
qu'une forme l'enseignement c'est le
totem d'un état et donc on doit être en
capacité de d'enseigner à nos élèves
tout ce qui existe tout tout ce qui est
face à eux et donc après à eux de les
amener à à à faire le choix sur sur ça
sur la concurrence déloyales les
potentiels épidémie de cancer pollution
voilà quel modèle les les jeunes
agriculteurs proposent chez jeunes
agriculteurs on considère et oui c'est
c'est un enjeu c'est comment on arrive à
maintenir une agriculture qui permet une
souveraineté alimentaire qu'elle soit
française européenne mondiale tout en
préservant un environnement sur lequel
on le pratique et et là-dessus je pense
qu'il faut qu'on aille plus loin sur
l'investissement dans les évolutions de
l'innovation sur la
recherche génétique sur tout ce qu'on
pourra mettre dans les moyens pour
accompagner la recherche et garantir
finalement un niveau de production parce
que personne ne peut se réjouir à se
dire que si notre outil de production
est détruit on aura plus rien à
transmettre et quand même la vocation
des agriculteurs au-delà de nourrir
c'est quand même la fierté de
transmettre un outil si c'est à leurs
enfants mais même à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est quand même la fierté de la
continuité tout ça et donc nous on est
convaincu que il y a pas un modèle exact
qui permettra d'y répondre par contre
c'est bien dans l'investissement
collectif dans la recherche je pense que
la recherche nous a permis de belles
choses et je pense que le le question et
nous nous sommes favorables sur le sujet
des NBT les nouvelles biotechnologie
sont potentiellement je dis bien
potentiellement mais il faut qu'on
cherche il faut qu'on y a des solutions
pour
résoudre et et baisser l'utilisation de
de produits phytoparmaceutiques mais il
y a un moment donné il faut faut en fait
qu'on soit dans la recherche et et nous
ce qu'on dit il faut pas qu'on
risque finalement la la production de de
de récolte qui serait un propre à la
consommation c'est arrivé et ça on peut
pas se le permettre en France ou en
Europe d'avoir des cultures où risquer
un zéro récolte je dis pas qu'on y est
je dis juste que il faut qu' qu' qu'on
soit en capacité et en plus on on a les
entreprises en France
sementières on a des chercheurs on a les
capacités il faut juste qu'on leur en
donne les moyens de leur dire voilà les
trajectoires qu'on veut et comment on va
de l'avant pour aller tendre vers le
moins d'impact possible sur
l'environnement dire qu'on aura zéro
impact je je pense que ça c'est
présentiux parce que la vie humaine a de
l'impact sur l'environnement qu'elle le
veuille ou non le fait qu'on soit sur
cette terre fait qu'on a un impact sur
elle après comment on essaie de le
limiter au maximum et comment on
garantit un préservation je pense qu'il
faut le faire mais moi ce qui me gêne et
c'est ce que je vous disais dans mes
propos limitaires c'est que pour moi on
réussira ça que si on le fait tous
ensemble tout secteur confondu et il
faut pas qu'on fasse porter le sentiment
bon là c'est normal c'est l'agriculture
mais je parle dans un discours plus
généraliste qu'en fait la clé résiderait
que dans le monde agricole pour
préserver cette planète sur
l'amélioration de l'indicateur eugalim
je pense que ça fait un moment que
c'était promis la la mission flash de
voir ce qui marche ou ce qui marche pas
il faut qu'on voit quel est l'indicateur
le plus je pense qu'on a des
interproffections quand même qui
existent dans différentes filières et
que il faut qu'on arrive à ce marche euh
on est tous conscient qu'il y a quand
même des postures et je pense qu'à un
moment donné il faudra qu' qu' metettent
des coups de pieds dans la fourmilière
pour faire que ces ces instituts qui
existent ces institutions qui existent
marchent vraiment parce que tous les
acteurs sont autour de la table et euh
doivent un moment donné se mettre
d'accord à sortir des coups de
production je pense que les chiffres on
les connaît tous on a suffisamment de
données dans ce pays pour être capable
de savoir combien coûte un litre de lait
à produire 1 kilo de viande et donc il
faut qu'on soit en capacité d'utiliser
ces indicateurs là avec quand même je
pense que tout le monde en est conscient
mais une contrainte malgré tout c'est
que il y a des réglementations qu'elle
soit europen ou ou mondial sur le
commerce et qu'on peut pas faire tout et
n'importe quoi en terme de San
sanctuariser un prix ou autrre et donc
faut aussi qu'on voit est-ce qu'il y a
des choses à changer au niveau européen
pour permettre une juste rémunération
des des
agriculteurs sur le guichet unique oui
on partage parce qu'on l'a porté mais
oui ça va changer notre face qu'on avait
de fonctionner parce que les les j ont
toujours été reconnus comme les les
acteurs de l'installation mais les j
sont aussi conscients que ce sont pas
les seuls sur l'installation et que sur
les 12000 installations il y en a une
bonne partie qui passe aussi par
d'autres organismes et donc il faut
aussi respecter les autres acteurs qui
existent sur le terrain et donc
considérer qu'il y a aussi des gens qui
veulent rendre là et donc si on veut un
guichier unique qui réunit tous les
acteurs vous pouvez pas exiger que ça
soit plus l'un ou plus l'autre qui qui
le commande donc après il faudra on voit
comment on adapte ça mais je pense que
c'est c'est une bonne chose sur les les
prêt bonifiés Vous vous l'aveit voté on
l'a poussé moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
regarde comment on le fait alors dans la
dans le PACT il y a ces 2 milliards de
prégaranties par l'État il faut qu'on
voit comment on peut agir je pense qu'il
y a certaines banques qui ont commencé à
à donner des signes qu'ils étaient prêts
à y travailler je pense qu'il faut qu'on
le travaille assez rapidement mais tout
en ne provoquant pas une inflation du
prix de la reprise si toutefois on
arriverait à trouver euh une
bonification sur sur les prêts euh sur
l'installation progressive on le partage
et ça c'est vrai que je l'ai pas
souligné mais c'est une déception à
l'heure actuelle dans la loi c'est sur
la question du droit à l'essai notamment
dans les Gaek il faut qu'on voit comment
on peut mettre en place pour que les
jeunes puissent essayer euh on a eu
poussé aussi à un moment donné des idées
de se dire comment on regarde alors le
statut du Gaek euh c'est technique mais
fait que si un associé quitte euh en
fait l'autre qui reste euh au bout d'un
an doit avoir retrouvé ou sinon il peut
pas garder la for je pense que il faut
qu'on voit sans dénaturer ceelga qui est
quand même une exception française et
qui est plutôt une bonne chose sur la
terme de pénibilité de travail de
dégagement de temps libre comment
l'aménage aussi peut-être à répondre à
des nouvelles envies permettre qu'un
jeune rentre progressivement dans la
structure puisse prendre le temps
d'essayer parce que moi pour l'avoir
vécu un an c'est quand même assez court
pour essayer parce qu'en gros vous avez
un mois d'essaiis derrière faut se
lancer dans les démarches pour être
installé au bout d'un an donc il faut
qu'on déverrouille aussi ça qu'on
rallonge peut-être aussi avec des
conditions parce que qu'on donne pas
aussi le prétexte d'avoir entre
guillemets un salariat déguisé sous
prétexte que on voudrait installer
finalement il y a jamais d'installation
mais VO je pense qu'il y a des choses à
travailler donc ça il faut il faut
vraiment qu'on qu'on le relance euh sur
les outremerses
euh moi je pense
que il y a une spécificité outreemère il
c'est pas plégtif mais d'une ils sont
plus implactés que nous encore par le
changement climatique j'étais il y a
quelques mois à la Réunion et et le
changement climatique faut qu'ils ont
quand même des pressions
euh de d'insectes ou autres qui qui
ravachent quand même des cultures et
donc si je prends 30 secondes l'île de
la Réunion certains tendent à dire il
faut qu'il fasse moins de canne et qu'il
faut qu'il se déversifie à la limite ça
peut s'entendre la la la problématique
c'est que quand vous discutez avec des
marchés ils sont en train de vous dire
que potentiellement le maréchamp
pleinchamp va devenir compliqué à la
Réunion vu qu'on leur a retiré des
molécules pour lutter quand ils ont une
une invasion d'insectes et qui ravage
les cultures et donc ils ont plus de
moyen de lutte ils utilisent la lutte
raisonnée mais donné quand il y a un
gros impact il n'y arrive plus donc il
faut qu'on voit comment on peut les
accompagner parce que si on veut
diversifier et rendre euh finalement ces
agricultures dans les différents
départements ultramarins solides il faut
aussi qu'on soit déjà en capacité de
leur amener des moyens de lutte contre
ces changement climatiqu qui sont
peut-être des fois plus violents que ce
que nous on perçoit sur sur la métropole
actuellement euh des structuration de
filières je pense qu'il y a il y a un
boulot à faire dans certains il faut
voir comment on peut accompagner les
expériences qui marchent en métropole à
nos collègues dans les départements
ultramarins pour voir comment on peut
les aider à se structurer comment on
peut avancer moi je l'ai porté auprès du
Premier ministre vous avez certains
départements ultramarins qui ça fait
déjà des années demande des IGP je pense
à l'ananas ou à d'autres et ça fait
bientôt 6 ans qu'ils sont en attente du
GGP ça prend trop de temps c'est trop
long il faut aller bien plus vite et moi
j'espère que là la les mobilisations
vont faire que les choses vont
s'accélérer parce que c'est une vraie
chance pour promouvoir les produits
les produits des des outres mèes je
pense qu'il faut qu'on regarde quand
même la spécificité du marché parce
qu'ils sont quand même ils ont ils sont
quand même considérés un peu hors Europe
sur le terme du marché ils ont des
droits qui s'appliquent pas nous et donc
ça il faut quand même que un moment
donné on peut pas les considérer hors
Europe moi je je c'est enfin dans le
logiciel je ne peux pas comprendre ça
donc ça il faut qu'on le revoit au
niveau européen comment on considère
mieux ces départements là comment on les
intègre mieux dans le marché et comment
eux on lutte contre une concurrence
déloyale qui est assez impressionnante
sur je pense à de laail ou autre qui est
fait en Inde enfin ou à la vanille de
Madagascar enfin c'est des trucs qui
viennent les percuter de plein fouet
sauf que vu qu'ils sont sur un marché un
peu différent du are en métropole on on
on une complexité à lutter contre ça
donc ça je pense qu'au niveau du au
niveau européen il faut qu'on revoit le
cadre législatif comment on les intègre
mieux dans le marché européen et qu'on
les sidère
pas à
part et pour les jeunes bah il faut
qu'on renforce l'accompagnement sur les
structure d'accompagnement sur ça et
puis la question du stockage de l'eau
enfin on l'a vu à mayott c'était assez
catastrophique ce qui s'est passé et
donc il faut aussi qu'on voit comment on
peut accompagner ça il faut vraiment un
plan fort moi je pense qu'il faut un un
un ministre
euh à voir comment on le fait mais il
faut vraiment gérer les outr mè qu' a
quelqu'un qui s'en occupe à temps plein
que ça soit sur des questions agricoles
sur non mais je vous le dis honnêtement
comme je le pense parce que il faut
aller sur les outremèes pour comprendre
le fonctionnement d'outr-em que si on
s'imagine gérer l'outrem comment on gère
la métropole on se trompe complètement
et c'est pas le faire offance de dire ça
c'est en fait c'est comprendre leur
spécificité c'est comprendre leur
particularités et j'y ai passé 10 jours
alors j'ai fait que la Réunion et les
autres voudraient que j'aille mais en
fait quand vous avez passé 10 jours vous
avez pris le temps d'aller voir toutes
les filières d'avoir discuté avec eux
vous comprenez très vite que la chose
elle est pas simple mais il y a plein de
choses à faire mais il faut juste qu'on
arrête de considérer qu'on va gérer ces
départements là comme on gère la
métropole ou alors en les laissant de
côté mais je pense qu'il y a des belles
opportunités en plus une jeunesse qui a
beaucoup envie ils ont des opportunités
donc il faut qu'on qu'on qu'on le raorte
qu'on leur apporte tout ça et et
fortement euh voilà ce que je pouvais
vous dire mais moi je il y a des belles
opportunités il y a une vraie richesse
et sur la la question qui m'a été posé
sur par la Confédération paysane sur le
marché bio c'est pas exactement ce que
j'ai dit
et j'ai dit que à un moment donné si je
pense qu'on a été trop vite sur la
montée en puissance des gens qui
produitent du a du bio et qu'on a
peut-être provoqué un décalage de marché
c'est ce que je dis et donc je suis pas
en train de remettre en cause les aides
qui existent je vous tiens aussi dire
que au en fin d'année il y avait 90
millions qui ont été annoncé plus les 50
millions qui viennent d'être annoncés
donc ça commence à faire une envelopp
c'est peut-être sûrement trop peu mais
ça va quand même dans le bon sens je
vous dire qu'on l'a qu'on la soutient
mais voilà et je pense que c'est pas
leur faire défaut que dire que à un
moment donné on a surchargé un marché
trop rapidement et moi je dis j'en suis
premi regretté parce que on a des
adhérents ja qui il sont installés pas
parce que c'était une opportunité de
marché c'est parce que c'était leur
conviction et c'est cela qu'on a planté
c'est ça qui est plus dramatique et donc
il faut qu'on voit comment on les en
sort comment on aide à les structurer et
moi ce que je trouve dommage c'est que
ça fait depuis 2012 que je suis engagé
chez jeunes agriculteur et ça fait
depuis 2012 que j'explique à certains
que plutôt passer leur temps à à nous
taper dessus euh et à dire qu'on en
avait rien à faire du bio et qu'on était
contre le bio et dire qu'on était des
antibiot ils auraient mieux fait de
structurer leur marché parce qu'ils
allaient vivre dans quelques années une
crise sans précédent qui allait mettre
en cause beaucoup de jeunes et qui
allait poser beaucoup de questions ce
que je regrette c'est peut-être d'avoir
eu
raison merci merci monsieur le Président
merci madame la secrétaire générale de
nous avoir consacré autant de temps et
d'avoir répondu précisément à l'ensemble
de nos questions et on vous souhaite bon
courage pour continuer cette
mobilisation parce qu'on a bien compris
que vous restez plus que jamais mobilisé
et ça ici au Sénat on sera toujours très
très ouvert et très à l'écoute de toutes
les questions touchant à l'agriculture
merci beaucoup merci à vous